[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast we are Julia Claudia
and Jackie I wasn't to everyone to be
more respectful put your name first I
would be more so like the my name first
who are you introducing us to do we have
so many new viewers today I never know
whether to act like a million new people
are watching you know what I mean like
shows growing man not my fault
there are some men Tamar days and they
feel like every once in a while we sort
of drive it all as a benchmark done yeah
but we also do like a little starter
kids sometimes when we feel as though
we've been grown yeah so I just when I
see my name climbing the charts I want
to introduce myself to the new toasters
who maybe haven't felt seen by me in
like a month
that's true hey guys I'm Jackie you can
find me I mean how's everyone going how
was everyone's day Margaret verified an
Instagram this morning this snacks are
she is just Margaret Margaret but she is
the snatcher and snatching up their
complete scent like that the Instagram
verification team over the IG said it
just made me more legit because I put it
in my bio like you like a number to show
on iTunes like who are they to not be
very bright you right it just took them
enough time you're so influential you're
selling eye mask we're so proud of you
we're so guys it was very exciting I had
no idea do you feel any different um no
I'm sure everything with Instagram it's
like we've hit a million powers and like
that's someone's dream and it's like but
I still suck right like I'm still
worthless and nobody cares about million
followers I'm still a huge [ __ ] loser
yeah precisely how I feel
well it's an honor to be back here just
hanging out with you guys again um I
watched so much TV yesterday
I can't even function because I haven't
spoken to a human being in about 12
hours I actually enjoyed how we did The
Bachelor like I watched it for hours
last night but because of their fake
cliffhangers like it's annoying to watch
it Monday night and Tuesday nights and
I'm like oh I wonder what happens with
clay did I just say watching it on Hulu
was such a premium experience because
they cut out coming up later tonight
like it's so noisy watch these are only
30 minutes right now it's like so much
stuff cut out that it makes it super
super great so I watched four episodes
of the bath
and I watched five episodes of 13
reasons why and I just I finished the
season spoil it what a [ __ ] stupid
ending that's all I'll say those kids
are idiots and they're dangerous and
something Bad's gonna happen and it's
gonna be clay Jensen's [ __ ] fault
he's an idiot
right final season I think next season
is the final season if they ended it
like this I would like the show was
[ __ ] trash like I can't believe that
like I spent 13 hours of my life
watching these [ __ ] morons just run
around town being idiots after they
should call it 13 hours of clay jets and
convincing people to be idiots 13 hours
why you shouldn't lie yeah it's 13
reasons why you should literally stay as
far away from this trash show as
possible you enjoyed it
wait speaking of shows that are
overextending on their expiration date
younger I actually had a theory as to
how it's gonna end okay just put on some
music no it's not a spoiler because I
don't know anything but I was just
thinking about a nice way for them to
wrap it up like you know I think the
nice day for them to wrap it up would be
if Liza just dies no this is what's
gonna happen
I came to me during SoulCycle this is
what's gonna happen
she is gonna write a book about her
experience being younger because she
really she's such a great editor she
loves the art of the of the written I'm
sure an interesting story and she has an
interesting story so like Charles will
go back to publishing she'll be a big
time magazine writer and you know then
they all work together and then she has
this whole new life but she gets to be
40 whatever and then she leaves the
sinking ship of the publishing house so
they can finally move on with their
lives like she's bringing down this
multibillion-dollar business it's so
frustrating to watch and everyone
they're like the only normal person
there is a the he was a cluttered let it
go she [ __ ] lied to us when did he
say that
oh no oh sorry no I didn't thank you oh
he's just the only one with a head on
his shoulders he's like why I keep this
picture up she's dragging us down yeah
like she's dragging Kelsey down but then
she also is the one who has like all the
good ideas and initially not that one is
a millennial she's not I'm sorry she's
not the only one with good ideas Kelsey
is incredibly good at her job
are you [ __ ] Kelsey is the worst at
her job you'll say Jackie Kelsey is the
worst and it's just waiting always for
someone to swoop in and save the day
know you'll say okay I'm gonna keep
watching even though it's so bad it's
great bad they're just hanging on
like this the premise of what the show
started as which is like she's yeah
you're but she's oh they're and it's
like we don't care anymore like just
make the show about these girls who live
in New York not having to always cling
to like the lie no and then when she
went to that retreat and she starts
going between Josh and Charles again
it's like no no no we're not going back
here no oh so what made our bed now
we're gonna lay in it and it's in a town
house uptown oh my god the best she's
even thinking about going back to that
Lulu loser he's frustrating no and the
fact that Charles sleeps at her
apartment makes no goddamn sense like
first of all like he has a nicer place
he doesn't have a roommate right and
like she works in the city so
logistically it makes no [ __ ] sense
it makes no [ __ ] sense and also
Charles deserves better than that loft
in Brooklyn okay he does oh he's an
Upper East Side townhouse coming I not a
loft in Brooklyn kind of guy the fact
that Kelsey is the CEO publishing house
and lives with a roommate and a baby and
another roommate I think I don't know it
says she says even someone's floor like
no yeah you expect to you being honored
or all these literary events when she's
literally living on the floor she's
joking these two mercury and millennia
like that everyone's like fighting over
it's like what about Simon Schuster
no that's what I just said to someone
who was watching they they talk about
like HarperCollins in Simon Shuster
which are real publishing houses they
talk about them in the show like that
it's not a fake publishing world they
liked very much exist in the ecosystem
of this business and they refused to
even admit that like maybe one of these
prestigious most sought-after authors is
gonna go to Simon and cheese or no
they're always going to mercury right
like there's time in Schuster
there's penguin there's Random House
like there are totally there are so many
I'm kelcie like was in barboonia fake
Suffolk house whatever like being an
embarrassment yep huge embarrassment
they're always like just [ __ ] like
taking their underwear off and spreading
their dirty laundry all over everyone's
this and what happened to her alopecia
and justice for Diana I actually like to
have a she's only one with a good sense
of business and a good one she only
wears some normal clothes to the office
yeah no she's like the only character
that's like developing in a in a real
way that I can get behind and she got
the best lines yeah and she's so firmly
based in reality like everyone else just
lives in a [ __ ] fantasy world yeah I
totally agree and I love Diana so that's
our review of younger weird odd Bhargav
oh okay
sorry that's just like snuck up on us
yeah it snuck up on us and then it
really got away from ya anyways we also
have to recap Oh see we'll do that at
the end of the show and then we're
taking all of our bachelor thoughts and
injecting them into this natural like
and your toes make it like a turkey
baster thank you I couldn't think I'm
like what do you shut up a vagina you
know a lot of things garlic that was the
most awful scene ever like I can't who I
just would like to understand the point
of the scene like Charles just like
sniffing Maggie's vagina at dinner like
I can't I can't I need to know the point
of the scene to move the plot forward
did you see the part yet when Maggie is
painting her feeling it chief ah yeah
now listen I like Maggie tip I love Debi
Mazar she's like the best concert does
she ever leave her apartment no she like
at Stockholm Syndrome and they're not
talking about it she's literally she's
agoraphobic yes she is honestly like one
of the funniest and most interesting
characters like I do wish she would
leave her house sometimes yeah but you
know what I like her wherever she is do
oh so we're doing gear toasters today so
I think usually that's all right I think
it's time to deliver to pacify stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast it's that fact apparently Liz Oh
played instead of our crunch today yeah
I just went back to listen to it because
I like didn't know and it did juice I
think that's really apt yeah come again
like instead of the crime huh Lizza
started playing honestly that [ __ ] me
once right it works for me too
okay first story Jeremy Webster makes
her red carpet debut Oh inside Kylie
Jenner and Travis Scott okay the first
family of the United States is snatching
up the red carpet because Travis Scott's
Netflix film came out last night I
didn't watch it I'm not like a huge
Travis Scott fan I kind of do want to
watch it because people talk about him
like he's like the second coming of
Christ like I'm so talented and I sure
world is such an experienced take me
back
so I actually also I want to see Kylie
so I do think I'm gonna watch it I think
so too
the one-year-old daughter of Kylie
Jenner and Travis Scott attended her
very first red carpet event tonight last
night and it's safe to say it won't be
the last the adorable toddler was on
hand to support her rapper dad at the
premiere of his upcoming Netflix
documentary Travis Scott look mom I can
fly dressed head-to-toe in camouflage
and tiny waist
hers swarmy pose for photos and looked
understandably a bit scared in the arms
of her world-famous mama okay I just
need to say everything about these
photos like I can't I shan't and I went
Kylie looks incredible they're really
turning into like the first family of
not even like TV because she's not
really on TV anymore like they're the
first family of like a culture of life
they are of America I'm obsessed I'm
obsessed I didn't even know how much I
needed them to walk a red carpet with
their daughter yeah until they did or I
didn't really know how much I needed
them to walk a red carpet together
because the only red carpet in recent
memory they did was through Grammys
where she wore that like pink jumpsuit
that just like wasn't it for me so this
white ensemble it's very much more it
and the Met yeah they walk together get
that one year who she walked with
Kendall this year so now I'm just seeing
it like in recent memory and the only
time I can really think of them ever
being out together on a red carpet is
that Grammys moment where they showed up
like literally the last people on the
carpet and her photos came in super late
like the award ceremony had already
started and I didn't even like her
outfit so this is much more what I
needed to get me through to the next red
carpet yeah but she doesn't do very many
no never unless she's like promoting
something yeah unless she's like getting
paid which I mean they're getting paid
for this movie so she's like she really
doesn't do that much like no I mean
obviously she's like a huge business but
all through meetings are from home like
do you think she really ever like wants
to see new people she sees like the same
20 people I feel like when she gets
bored like she can do stuff like she'll
rent out an amusement park and then
that's enough fun you know blast you all
so it's like when you're a mom actually
you don't get bored oh for sure like
you're just you're creating life like
how boring could that be and like if she
gets worried she'll get another dog
right or maybe make another child she's
gonna do that soon yeah I was just like
loving being a snatched mom you know
she's a snatcher
she is this sudden and alert mom yeah I
agree but I think she loves being a mom
and she gets snatched
getting sad for her so easy yeah and
also she just has those Jenner genes
like that's really nice yeah do you
think I mean I think in a lot of ways
Kylie and Travis have been like a
mutually beneficial relationship for
each other like obviously that a child
and like they like each other but I
think it definitely like cemented Kylie
as like an older like I don't know I
just think
him like settling down with her gave her
respect but then her settling time with
him also gave him obviously right that's
what I was thinking and they're like a
mini Kim and Kanye they really are also
he's such an upgrade from Tyga no it's
when I I was just watching oh my god
they were playing old episodes of
Kardashian's and remember they went to
st. Bart's and they had like Kourtney do
that it's like feel-good photo shoot it
was like so cringy and then Kendall and
Kylie were fighting the whole time
because Kendall was upset that Kylie
brought time kendall was showing the
wrong in that episode I ever stop
complaining but then Tyga was just there
with Chris and he was talking with this
tattoo he got of Kylie like I can't
believe that they were like so legit and
strong for so long like he was like
trash yeah if he brought us blac chyna
yet yeah but then so did Robin no but
like they wouldn't actually that's not
true and not fair because Kim was
friends with blac Chyna before yeah she
was in the mix yeah but it was just like
such a bad look for the family yeah but
he was kind of good to Kylie I feel even
though I'm just saying antilles already
boiled her in terms of like optics like
he is not a real singer like I've never
heard any of his songs like he is like
low level like wannabe rapper and like
Travis Scott it's like single handedly
at creating music festivals like that is
so much more the level Kylie needs to be
be it to be on but like when you're such
a successful woman you think like do I
need to like date down no Kylie found an
equal yes she did now but when she was
dating taga like she was still coming up
to you so it worked for the time I'm
sure she has no regrets but this this is
her forever
I really hope so I really like they're
such a cute family these pictures like
there's just something so royal ya know
Kylie of those shoes like she literally
looks like the first lady that pony she
looks like the first lady because you
know I can't stop looking at it I want
to see like all the photos from the
night because I only have seen two
because she doesn't take a bad photo the
kid is so [ __ ] cute I'm just I'm so
obsessed how do the Kardashians like
make it seem
make it so that like all their grandkids
are cute I don't know like what happens
if there was like what and I see some
ugly kids like it's not all kids are
beautiful sorry but like you know what
if one of them just came out like how is
how are all four of Kim's kids like so
unbelievably beautiful like I don't know
who's the cutest like I want to say
saint-- but like also Chicago
and we'll see what happens to Sam we
called Sam notice um he's nobody home
Sam you think oh that seems so awkward
yeah that's too normal like Sammy I
think I don't know I haven't heard that
did I just make that up I don't know why
there's like a percent true cuz you're
probably hoping that it's true cuz it
like it looks awesome
Sam is it's hard that L yeah it's like
silent but not mom yeah it's like Psalm
is like 50% letters that don't exist you
know yeah that's what's so hard about it
cuz it's a P they'll kind of um still
happy for Kylie she's in such a good
place in her life this is just happy
news all around
totally okay next story a cheering gives
emotional goodbyes he announces 18-month
break from music oh my god he was gonna
say Cheryl oh no this is interesting cuz
we were just saying yesterday how he's
always on tour and like live streaming
his concerts in from award shows always
and now after more than 250 performances
on the road ed Sheeran may be headed
back to the cow bone sorry Lizzy I just
made a great call
Nora's black book the Instagram account
makes fun of the kid by calling him Sam
so I guess that's why I thought they
called him Sam because I think that
account is real thankful is I'm sorry
that account he's sometimes endorsed by
like Chloe
Kanye posted one Kanye in the Instagram
for like a week and he went crazy he
screamed out I was like this is funny
yeah so I think that gives it legitimacy
on the final stop of his divided tour
earlier this week the Grammy winner
began thinking out loud and announced
his break from music as you may or may
not know I've been on the divide tour
for over two years now and this is the
last day of the whole thing he told the
crowd in England according to the Sun
there is something very bittersweet
about it I love that you guys are here
and we are ending in Ipswich she
continued this is my last gig for
probably 18 months honestly so deserved
and no not even deserves so good but as
we learned from the One Direction
documentary when you're out when your
life is tour album tour album tour album
in hysterics toxic and that's what
Taylor's have said on the Ryan Seacrest
show yesterday she said I'm not even
thinking about planning a tour for lover
because I cannot have my life be tour
album she said I literally just took off
my tights from the reputation tour and I
can't on my life be tour album tour
album try album so as much as I would
love my life to be Twitter album tour
album to album I think for like mega
stars like engineering it's probably a
good decision what's crazy noise I
remember ed Sheeran
this announcement a few years ago that
he took some time off of music and we
learned him back and I guess time flies
because he came back he put out a Bangor
album he did 250 tour dates in two years
and like now here we are again when it
feels like he made that announcement a
year ago no it's like he just works he
like he just wants to live his life but
he works every few years to get his
artistic like you know juices flowing
also makes some good money and then he
stops working goes like he lives like a
very normal life a small life in Ireland
with his wife I feel like he really you
know appreciates work-life balance yeah
and I know takes it seriously which is
something not and like I know it's kind
of a joke it's something not enough
artists to agreed Ariana Grande Ariana
Grande yeah I mean in like the
Millennial culture we're all about
work-life balance and no one is more
balanced than me no me too little to
balance but also it's only when you get
to a level like only the part of the job
of being famous and being a celebrity is
having to continually work so that you
don't become irrelevant yeah so only
people like Taylor Swift like Ed Sheeran
can afford to take 18 months off and
come back and be just as famous if not
more famous as when they left yeah but
if bebe Rexha stopped right now and
didn't work for 18 months we would like
that's just the way the Machine worked
yeah so like they're only there even Kim
like Kim could not stop writing she she
could not stop working for 18 months
like her whole brand is always being
relevant yeah I agree with that also you
have to have already like enough money
to take off 18 months and like live at
the level you want to live three months
run out of money except Adela you need
that famous you may be a talented artist
enough that like whenever you come back
like whatever you put out is gonna be so
good that people are gonna love it like
hold them over yet or even if she's
irrelevant for eight months and no one's
talking about her and she's not making
any money like when she does come back
like people are gonna want to hear what
she has to say yeah same with Ed Sheeran
I don't know about actually Dini works
like writes Fox but it's just different
like association like albums like what I
wouldn't make her right she's a pop star
yeah what I wanted to say also it's like
when you but when you are off for that
18 months you're not not making money
like you're actually making a ton of
money they have so many revenue streams
that are built and they put in place
just to continually make money to like
sustain their lifestyle like an even
like songwriter credits like Ed Sheeran
has written every song ever he's making
money but not as much as he's making an
on tour he goes working or when he's
selling
enormous stadium but it's kind of rift
is he just dropped an album today
oh the claps yeah hear about it he did
with the Eminem song oh wait extra that
I was good yeah but it's like he doesn't
that song he doesn't need to torn that
album because he'd have to bring
everyone right I guess she's got the
brown eyes care about that is that songs
about and beautiful people I don't care
also the 50 cent one's pretty good I
love that one
how does this go it's like yeah I just
like it's not a song I think I can say
I'm just I know but it's really
bothering me how does it go um what's it
called remember the name okay well can
you look it up or something really
bothering me that album was good I
forgot but that's not like a real album
either looks like a fun project he
wanted to do because he wanted to like
make a song with Chris Stapleton so you
know you just like needed an excuse
that's insane blow I don't like their
just scream cheering hit song has to
play on the radio 100 times for me to
give a [ __ ] about it I don't know why I
just item not like it's your aunt or
woody
honestly it wasn't good oh you know
Eddie my time to call it a day I wanna
be paid but it's on me remember that
name hey no I'm loving though of the new
edge here and on the scene
Louis Capaldi I love he plays Larry in
every [ __ ] restaurant in budget guy
that I'm ever in and then things rise up
Linton's
nine holes Shazam is filled with Luis
Cavalli and like the same songs I'm like
I like this song what is it
does anyone else associate Luis Capaldi
with the Jonas Brothers for some reason
no I think they're friends with him I
don't know but he's really good I don't
know what he looks like I just knew they
might say he's like he gives me like
what's that song that when we were kids
oh my god [ __ ] yeah James Wyatt he gives
me James Lutton guides yeah a little
less weird no but like James funk just
like was the one-hit wonder let's see
about what was the definition of a
one-hit wonder there's so many but no
but like I feel like when they when they
when they teach a one-hit wonder in
music school they should use Daniel
Powter as an example dunno yeah because
he not only did he literally have one
[ __ ] hit it was real
a hit like to this day there are some
emotions that can only be you know
personified through that song cuz you
had a bad day you take one cow you sing
sad song just turn it around
yes but now we have now the two hit
wonder is the thing with Billy Ray Cyrus
oh that's so true no he's a he's not a
TV hit wonder he's a twice one-hit
wonder okay there's a difference you
know a two-hit wonder means you had two
hits yeah but like one hit means
achy-breaky heart was huge enemies then
it came back yeah yeah Oh back at it
again yeah you're right he's so crazy
when he gave a speech at the VMAs I just
like kind of loved him yeah am i here it
is but I think Billy Ray Cyrus is cute
when he took his head off and thank the
Lord Jesus Christ at the VMAs I thought
that was really sweet yeah and he had
hat hair so it was really brave
I thought the same thing okay he wasn't
the same say next up we have a CMA Award
nominations very exciting here in the
nominees for album of the year Center
Point Road Thomas Rhett cry pretty
Carrie Underwood dan + Shay by dan +
Shay desperate man by Eric Church girl
by Maren Morris it's a tough competition
album of the year yeah obviously I want
Mara Mars cuz that's the album that I
listen to the most I'm not really
familiar with somebody please Center
Point Road Center for th loves very good
right pretty very good except for that
one song that should meet a single I
like that song no I can't
Johnny bad I love that I heard on the
radio you both were like this [ __ ]
sonic how much made a single i'm like in
the car look i know like the song
[ __ ] slaps I like it and like I was
like not a song Carrie Underwood should
be sick it's too cold look that it
reminds me of just Leighton Meester in
Country Strong yes how great is that
okay keep going a little sad damn shame
I didn't change I just feel like they
won't won't is that like all nighter no
that's an x-ray
that was good yeah really I remember
listening to that album last summer when
the mountains yeah but they're finally
getting the respect desperate man by
Eric Church I haven't listened but I
tried by Mary Morris I'd be happy with
honest Annie I mean I'm sorry am I
missing something where is Balu combs
his album or it was last year so true
what album oh that's true was it last
year yeah this one's for you yeah yeah
yeah wouldn't that wouldn't be it but
nominated musical event of the year all
my favorite people Mary Morrison
brothers I was born ready by the way I
just need to say that song it's a
[ __ ] big grand new man Brooks & Dunn
Holmes dive bar Garth Brooks and Blake
Shelton Old Town Road
I don't think CMAs are gonna give their
respects at lil nas and Billy riding a
[ __ ] I think I I think they might I'm
just saying I think I think think they
totally should and it's 2019 I think
they might I feel all over the place
when it comes to little nas and that and
the country world because I really see
it as a great opportunity to like
embrace this new like digital era and
and all that but a lot of the the cygnus
women asked in interviews like how they
feel about old-timer they're like we
think it's so great but like the they're
like poking fun at our lifestyle yeah we
do drink beer on tractors like and it's
like making fun of us I guess but like
they'll not show us okay everything like
as a cowboy I think he really just can't
he just like country culture I know I I
don't think so I mean I'm not like a
country Mike person through and through
so I can't say if it's offensive but I
don't think it is I don't know either
but I'm just saying like I Luke home
said that like like he it's funny but
like he's everything kind of like what
he does like sitting in a barn and you
know drinks to you yeah I see both sides
me too I got they embrace him though
because he really has done wonders for
country music even though they did take
it off the country card charts are a bit
in honor of it they keep changing it but
right now it's country okay I think he
really likes his horse and like well
we'll be there we will be there okay new
artist of the year
Cody Johnson Carly parse Midland Ashley
McBride Morgan Wallen whoo now I want to
get my
though to Carly Parks but Morgan wall
and it works with Diplo and I'm sure and
I do think Morgan Wallen will win I
think Carly really no I think Cody
Johnson's gonna win oh he's like very
he's like a real country you have to see
this category pretty thin yeah I thought
the same thing these are all people who
have been around for Toms who said Carly
parts if she was ever gonna win best
artists I think it would have been last
year but she's been she's been a new
artist for a long time right so no yet
the competition isn't stiff here no
Entertainer of the Year Garth Brooks
Chris Stapleton Keith Urban Carrie
Underwood Eric Church same every [ __ ]
year the same every [ __ ] year and I
have to say like I do want some female
representation but I don't think Carrie
Underwood was the Entertainer of the
universe Graves is the Entertainer of
the Year I'm not lining every single
mention of one nomination not in this
short ready here's some female said I
think really could have been included in
this category Kacey Musgraves Kelsea
Ballerini doesn't stop [ __ ] working
and she represents country music in a
very classy beautiful way I know better
so that's what I was gonna say I mean he
really is the Entertainer engineer Kacey
Musgraves is the Entertainer of the Year
in country music sorry she won the
Grammy
she's headlining festivals she's
crossing over like no other Lollapalooza
Coachella I couldn't agree we refuse to
see these festivals in Canada and she's
out here like representing country music
and like a new wave of like inclusive
country music LGBTQ rights for country
music yeah not not cool i pointing the
cma like crew like whoever like they're
like they're like such an old school
boys club nobody I don't think anyone
takes them seriously anymore because
it's just like they do they're jaded
not even read the Lambert's nominated
well I love that but like she's a staple
she's a Chris Stapleton okay we have
some more nominations single of the year
Burning Man Dierks Bentley Brothers
Osborne in love great so we're all over
Stars God's country Blake Shelton
millionaire Christy Elton I've never
heard that so old Beach less Dan and J
so old I am I don't like that song God's
country I love that song God's country
like
it was like I could have told you the
tune before I heard the song no it's a
con on an old song yeah also say what
that song he'll write but that doesn't
make sense well that's okay right like
that's what I knew it was gonna be
before I heard the song did you hear
about that new singer who sings the song
toast do you think she was nominated for
anything I don't think she was because I
think next year it'll be like her best
new artist she's coming out with an
album like people are saying I don't
know if it's true it's just a rumor but
I don't so maybe next year will be her
year but maybe she'll do like a little
red carpet perfect she must be she must
be so upset here she's gonna be at the
red carpet performance I heard she's
really upset about moon song of the year
beautiful crazy Luke combs girl Maren
Morris God's country Devin Dawson
oh no he wrote a rainbow Shayne McAnally
and Kacey Musgraves and tequila tequila
was the song of last year movie yeah
they're tequila rainbow beautiful crazy
beautiful crazy so he's on the radio and
yeah I just don't know what they what
goes into them choosing like I feel like
with the Grammys I started to understand
like a lot of it has to do with sales at
a lot of it has to do with the person
and like their platform I kind of I feel
like I can always understand who wins
the Grammy but the CMAs like I never
really understand what the thought
process is behind who they choose you
know yeah I think it's like a board I
think so too
okay female vocalist of the year Kelsea
Ballerini Miranda Lambert marinara's
Kacey Musgraves Carrie Underwood QC most
very sad but very Ferries male vocalist
of the year Dierks Bentley lue combs
Thomas Rhett Chris Stapleton Keith Urban
I need Lee combs to get the respect that
he deserves this year I think you know
what's I don't think it's his year he's
in between albums at this award show
like the album comes out in November
then next year right and sweeps I would
love for him to get the respect but then
that would mean that he can't sleep
again next year
you know so he won with some maybe one
one yeah vocal group of the year lady a
little big town so Claudia's gonna vote
for them Midland Old Dominion Zac Brown
Band wow so many it never gets any pods
their little country but like nah but
they haven't put out a new music in a
while sacrament is putting out in music
you look at that the most recent Rascal
Flatts album didn't come out so long ago
did it well 2017
yeah I don't understand why like why
they won't place
a coach like oh my god it's [ __ ]
Rascal Flatts headline stagecoach I
would need Molly yeah I would die I
would be on Molly without taking Molly
yeah I would my head which is exceeding
my body I would die like I would
literally die there's such like a weird
like they're like Celine Dion you know
they're like like touring their greatest
hits but they keep coming up with new
music yeah that that's good sense yeah
like some of their new songs are their
best song me too got your life back to
life I don't like to see you here's
years old here's to you is the best
Rascal Flatts song ever I feel like me
to listen to country music you've
literally have no idea what we've been
talking about the last one I know no but
like we're always talking about the same
stuff okay next story a bit of OC news
that I found to be interesting because
Gina Gershon hiders husband ex Matt
claims he lost his job over arrest and
reveals her real houses Orange County
salary over her arrest or his arrest her
arrest yes I saw that she makes sixty
eight thousand dollars a year from last
season
Oh sixty-three thousand by production
and then fifty four fifty by
NBCUniversal which is I don't understand
Matt kirshen hide their claims had a
strange way Gina was paid sixty three
thousand dollars by production and five
thousand four hundred fifty dollars by
NBCUniversal
for thirteen of Rioja see Susan thirteen
the one we're currently watching her the
last one I believe it's one we're
currently watching her though Real
Housewives of Orange County sergeant
Jeana kirshen Haider and her estranged
husband Matt are still fighting over the
terms of their divorce earlier this
month the former couple who share sons
Nicolas Luca as well as daughter Sienna
appeared to have come to a custody
agreement with Jeana getting primary
custody of their kids and nearly ten
thousand dollars in monthly support but
according to documents obtained by
people Matt claims that Jeana is now the
primary moneymaker whereas he is
currently unemployed and has no income
representatives for both of the Kirsten
hiders did not immediately respond to
people's requests for comment literally
this family is like falling apart yeah
yeah I can't like Shirley made $70,000
from what is it like eighteen episodes
yes I was actually really curious what
it would be because she's a second
season like it's not but this is her job
so that's like getting $63,000 like as
your annual income which is pretty good
for a year - I know but like not for TV
cuz can you break it down by episode
let's say there's 18 episodes and she's
making
to $8,000 journey no but plus housing
from production sounds like it was
reimbursements or something / 18
that's 3,700 in episode I know that in
the very beginning the kids from siesta
key where we get like 5 grand an episode
that's really low for a second year look
she couldn't ago she ated that more can
we just double check that season 13 OC
is this one right like what current
season of OC are we in right now I just
need to confirm season 13 episode oh no
that's like last season is season 3 oh
okay great
I hope it's doubled at least yeah or
even though I feel like maybe she's
signed like a two-year contract where
she like couldn't get like she would
just be happy to get a second season
I don't think Bravo would sign a
two-year contract on a new housewife
who's kind of around no but like in her
contract for the first year was like if
you if we decide to keep you on like you
get the same payment like there's
they're so cheap yeah it's possible it's
possible but they did say season 13 he
didn't he could have said two seasons
120,000 right right yeah that's true I'm
just I'm Chuck I mean that makes a lot
more sense for being a first season but
like so they have no income anymore like
they're just living off of her
housewives checks that's bad like that
is what when Andy when I read his books
he said like the housewives always the
worst part and he said it happens a lot
in OC as the men stop working not that
he decided to stop working but like in a
lot of cases like the husband stopped
working and they put all their eggs in
the basket of like the housewives them
and them both becoming so famous and
then if they get fired or quit like in
their lives are in shambles and he said
he said so many husbands calling like
begging for their wives to get their
jobs back how sad is that that's really
sad
but he's blaming his firing on her
arrest which I can't imagine it's true
and or I can't imagine is legal oh so
I'm pretty sure the woman he had the
affair with and is now dating was
someone who is working with so egg maybe
HR busting his oh that's truly the 19
'she's enough going on no she's like not
okay I'm not like the biggest Gina stand
but back off yeah like just cuz you got
fired by the way they weren't even they
were divorced so your ex-wife getting
arrested should have no bearing on your
pull on your career stand especially
because she's kept you anonymous for so
long so now actually you're in the press
because of your court for but she's kept
in him anonymous but her name is Gina
Niner and his name is Matt like she
didn't really keep his name anonymous no
but it's not like we ever saw a picture
of him we ever saw a picture of him in
knew where he works he worked somewhere
in LA like Pete I don't think it was
ever like he was his employer was
getting calls or like he was getting
snapped outside the office I have to say
of all the housewives has seen coming on
the show her like entry into the show
has been such a [ __ ] [ __ ] like
her
Emilie both between the caseta the
divorce and now the affair they just
rolled it they steam rolled in yeah and
it's it's really weird because now it
feels like Emily's gonna get a divorce
emily is not in a good place and I'm
really sad that she's continuing to do
the dance because he's obviously not
into it no she has to do the dance and
get divorced otherwise just to dance her
way to the divorce otherwise it's weird
otherwise she's dancing her husband
won't watch her dance and she's gonna
like support him yeah I just feel like
there's something they're not telling us
when it comes to Emily because none of
its making any sense I just like I hate
these two I can't understand it's like
it's problematic because when Shannon
went through all that like we already
loved Shannon and we wanted to see it
through with her but for someone to come
in and only bring us negativity in pain
it's like why might I have enough in my
own life why would I watch you I don't
know you and the fact that Jeana Kirsten
Heiner has never been to our Jo drive
was like making me really sad because
they took her and they took her to a
boutique that they could film in
obviously obviously like it was pathetic
it was quite that and to channa be for
her clothes I think so I hope so when
they shoot
Emily having a panic attack outside I
thought at first her panic attack was
gonna be about the fact that all the
ladies are like loving Jeana now and
Emily's never been like more on the outs
and like Jeana was her one life raft but
then she just started having like a
random panic attack about nothing about
her life like she just has so much going
on in what she won't say because if she
does stay with her husband like she's
not gonna you can't recover from that I
can't so she won't say like I'm in a bad
place but my husband I'm just trying to
stay afloat but she's just saying I'm
just trying to stay afloat as if she has
so much going on her life like makes me
really sad but she has so much joy if
she has a family she is great in like
she's oh right rounded by like love but
I feel for I feel like she does have so
much on her plate yeah I feel really bad
for her she makes me sad and I feel like
she's a lot of potential she's an
attorney
and the party planner I know like what
is weird dichotomy I feel like you could
take one thing off your plate if you
yeah right now between the kids the
planning of the parties the lawyering
like one thing can go and I think it
should be the party bonding but what she
says it's like the party planning makes
me have their passion right it's really
sad like her life was so [ __ ]
pathetic yeah and I think she has so
much potential to be a fun housewife
like every now and then we get like
small like glimpses into like church
she's actually a funny girl yeah and I
think she has a great spirit me too but
it's constantly we do this dance like
that she like film that whole thing she
has good intentions she's just always
been like let down but I like people
around her yeah and then she's lashing
out at the right the wrong person I'm
adore the frozen fish yeah that was not
cool not cool and like made virtually no
sense yeah she knew it wasn't well let's
finish recapping OC now and then we have
the historians kind of it just said yeah
why they're more honest like nothing
really happened I feel like I was really
confused by the entire thing because I
just want to be clear that Tamara was
the one who brought up the train yeah
and even though Bronwyn told Kelly which
was the right thing to do Kelly brought
her into the screw but Bronwyn didn't
tell her on camera it never came up like
so she I think she did that she was
fighting the blue to everyone acting
like Bronwyn is the villain Oh Tamra you
brought it up yeah and now I understand
why Kelly is so mad it's hammertime her
not only said the word trained she
described it in the car she cut them and
then she said this is about Shannon and
Vicki and I actually would say the most
innocent party here is Vicki yeah well
she said is I know thinks that's a bit
that's a big a very vague threat that if
no one said anything else would be like
okay like assume the worst about Kelly
no but all the ladies like imploded when
when Vicki just said one thing that was
sounded like a threat but it was it
Vicki didn't do anything right in this
moment I'm I totally understand why
Kelly's mad at Shannon Tamra
yes okay I just love Shannon I love
Shannon and I loved hammer too and I
don't understand how she doesn't see
that like this is all on her yeah no and
and everyone like Faye coming for
Broadman was making absolutely no sense
the second person who's totally out of
line is Emily bringing it up at the
table when you were the only person who
wasn't there and he cites
really just brought that up to be in the
storyline the season and it was so cheap
it was so cheap I feel so bad for Kelly
like I know Kelly's crazy and the way
that you felt about Shannon when she was
going through her bad years and like
always saw the good in her like I really
do feel that way about Kelly like do I
think she liked parties hard and like
maybe had a threesome
sure do I give a [ __ ] no is it
appropriate to be bringing up on TV like
when she has a kid and like she's
probably having like a custody battle
with her husband no it's not appropriate
like I don't care what goes on behind
closed doors and like the ladies of OC
have really like lost their minds these
past few years just bringing out like
the craziest [ __ ] in the hopes of it
saving their show and like making it
interesting and it's not working and
it's at Kelly dad's expense and it said
Jolie's expense and I really I I Stan
Kelly Dodd
I completely agree they're so below the
belt and it's also irrelevant say that
it's true and I don't even know things
are true say both things are true okay
how does that have any bearing on Vicki
being a bad friend right also like the
fact that this is just a rumor that they
heard and they said it was a rumor and
now it's really like just cuz you hear
something like doesn't mean that it's
true at all at all and doesn't mean that
it needs to be spoken about like I don't
understand typically where there's smoke
there's fire but this isn't like a smoky
situation like we've heard that like a
smoky situation like we've heard that
Kelly like likes trains on the rag not
like I heard that Kelly did it once and
you know what Kelly's a [ __ ] single
woman she's now famous she wants to get
trained that's her business
it's I long as she doesn't have a sex
tape even if she does I don't care yeah
but I feel like people even talking
about it like if she wants to do that
it's like so harmful because it's like
there's no proof that she did this is
something that happened you know I
forgot to put her Michael party today I
smell oh good thing we have this table
between us because we've talked about
our love of Ko parties aluminum-free
coconutty odorant before we wants let
you guys know that they've got an
amazing news sent and called driftwood
and it's the first charcoal deodorant
from Kapaa REE charcoal is like having a
moment charcoal is like the Erika Jayne
of elements like people obsessed with
the klm element it draws out toxins so
you've heard us talk about the original
coconut Yoda at the beach and gardenia
scents and the fragrance free version
but Co party's new driftwood scent
smells like a sandalwood and cedar wood
with middle notes of zesty clove it's
also with made with activated charcoal
which works to drive sweat and toxins
and absorb odor causing bacteria exactly
what you want to do durin aluminum's
hence it with like the whole aluminum
free organic deodorant but ever since
switching over to cope re when they
first started sponsoring the show like
almost a year ago I can definitely say
my Bo has really gone down in its
strength and its smell I love the smell
of the aluminum deodorants I love the
feel of it it's not sticky and it
doesn't leave residue on my clothing and
I just feel as though I'm a much better
person now I'm having used aluminum
children that's like the first thing
after the Kourtney Kardashian the first
thing and moving forward to like being a
more wholesome better person you know ya
know because right so instead of GMOs
baking soda parabens hope our children
keeps you fresh with plant-based actives
like sage oil and coconut oil it's great
if you've got sensitive sin and if you
don't just want a bunch of questionable
ingredients in your body most of all you
never have to worry about running out of
children because you can get cope re
automatically shipped to you as often as
you choose for free plus cope re
offensive offers a money-back guarantee
go to cope re Beauty Calm / toast to
save five dollars off your first
deodorant order when you subscribe
that's cope re KO PA RI beauty.com /
toast cope re Beauty Calm / toast 420
for five dollars off your first she owed
or in order when you subscribe sign on
snowman if you think totally okay the
mantel story just a little weather news
all eyes on Dorian as tropical storm
barrels toward Puerto Rico so it is not
again it's hurricane season and Bethany
is busy because Bethany said she was
going to send a plane to the Amazon so
like this is a crisis and her eyes are
over there and if Puerto Rico I don't
know if she can handle it I know well
just a little weather warning for
everyone after impacting the Lesser
Antilles on Tuesday tropical storm
durian began to unleash heavy rain and
strong winds across Puerto Rico in the
US and British Virgin Island Islands on
Wednesday wonder if that includes
Jeffrey Epstein's Island I hope so burn
it to the ground after they get all the
evidence
as of early Wednesday Dorian's maximum
sustained winds were 60 miles per hour
as he tracked Northwest at 13 miles per
hour
about 85 miles from st. Croix chocolate
we're in the crimson capital storm force
winds extend outward about 60 miles from
the center of the storm and additional
strengthening is likely in the coming
days as it pulls away from the Caribbean
so to all of our toasters in the
I mean please be safe this weekend yeah
I hope our Caribbean toasters are
boarded up yeah
our Puerto Rican toasters oh my god just
is it hurricane season again it is
August and it's just it's just like it
comes back every year you know it feels
annual I hope Bethenny is you know
preparing properly yeah but that guy who
Dorinda cussed out in Miami that was
that was still like to this day one of
the craziest scenes of television ever
like the disrespect and the level of of
alcoholism was really problematic
I completely agree I hope Dorinda has
like you know when you think of a moment
in your life when you were in like a
real low and you think of it and like
you cringe and like you never want to
get that moment out of your head I hope
during to feels that way about that one
because I feel that way about it for her
but I'm afraid that she doesn't I don't
know what now that Bethenny's gone I
feel I've been thinking about Bethenny's
absent Parcher and I feel like she's
really the one that holds him
accountable and just like holds him to a
higher standard and makes him live in
reality and I think that that's all
gonna be on the way no like LuAnn has no
one to answer to now I know and I'm
deeply afraid I've been thinking about
it a lot as well and I'm very upset and
scared
agreed should we jump into your toasters
you should see George advice we've got
some they're too loud dear toasters is
our advice segment you can email us dear
toasters at gmail.com we do it all
anonymously the weirder the better we
get some crazy ones like if you're you
know boyfriend is joining into a sperm
work sperm bank how do you feel about
that
dear toaster to gmail.com anything from
work to brides to family stuff we answer
it also looks dive right in
dear toasters Anonymous here's the
background I'm 22 and my oldest sister's
29 in expecting her first baby in
December they want the baby's gender to
be a surprise at birth okay so while ago
before she was pregnant I would luckily
share with my family what I want my
future girl named baby baby named to be
when I said that me my oldest sister
said oh I like that name she never
mentioned it before that ever about a
month ago my middle sister told me that
our oldest sister's top girl named
choice is the name I told my family that
I loved I was so upset because even
though I'm not having a baby anytime
soon this meant that I wouldn't be able
to pick the name I've thought about for
so long I let it settle for a few weeks
and this week my brother-in-law told my
mom and all of his family that it's
their top girl name it seems like
everyone else is being told about this
except for me at this point I'm more
upset about the principle of her using
it
being it from me when she knows it would
bother me more than the name itself am I
being Cuddy to say that to say to her
that it bothers me I'm afraid she'll act
like the woman had sex in the city did
to Charlotte and act like she didn't
know I would never ever ask her not to
pick it because I understand she's
having the baby not me but I know if the
roles were reversed it would be the end
of the world please help with what I
should do before she gives birth lol
love you girls stay toasty oh my this is
literally an episode of hard of course
you have to she's saying like I honestly
the fact that she's taking it isn't what
bothering me it's like she's telling
everyone I'm hearing it from like a
bunch of people on the perimeter but no
one has told me this is what my name ate
like when that girl stole my wedding
venue do you remember no yes you do no
okay I'll tell you after cuz I don't
want to say but literally that's that's
not a big two people can get married at
the same venue when you have two cousins
that but you both want to name them
that's permanent [ __ ] like honestly
that's not no but it was just similar
like okay I didn't end up getting an
hour there like one because I didn't
want to go to a wedding
a month before mine like at the place
and two I went and I just like didn't
like it but it was like it was my goal
it was my dream venue forever
now I remember and there's like the way
that she told me was like it wasn't
about the action it's always about the
delivery like the way that she told me
was just like so shady shake yeah we're
like doing it they're like yeah we're
sure but mine was different like that's
why if I said I was getting married at
the Plaza like okay everyone like that's
not special mine was different it was in
the play center when she was in outer
boroughs I hadn't ever heard of anyone
getting married there and I'd been
talking about it for years like mine was
unique so that theory doesn't apply I
just want to say no idea what you're
talking I'll tell you about it I didn't
even know this was a thing no it's not
but it just reminds me okay well when it
comes to this name I really don't know
how to guide you because on the one hand
like I feel you and that's plagiarism
name plagiarism but on the other hand
like you're not having a baby you're and
doesn't sound like you have one like
coming down in the pet blood if a person
who's having the baby gets to name their
baby first and like maybe if you were
like also pregnant you could like lace a
you could start getting some embroidered
[ __ ] and like you could win the name but
like she's having the baby first like
she gets the name okay but but her
problem isn't that she told them stole
the name it's that like no one's telling
her about it and
doesn't make her look petty if she says
I'm mad that you didn't tell me uh yeah
because I think when people say that -
it's not about what you did it's the
delivery it's like that it's what you
did right even if you delivered in
another way I would say I wish I
delivered it this way right no one I I
literally hate that excuse so much it's
like I just wish you told me sooner or
you said it this way like I'm not a
puppet
I didn't write me a script I said it the
way that I said it so she's upset about
the name if the woman told her
personally that wouldn't make her not
upset and the ones that Nene leaks I
said what ice she would say oh you know
what I'm upset that you that you're
telling me now that you didn't tell me
sooner it's always something else so
like that is a horseshit exceed that's
why you don't tell people your baby
names agree but I think just across the
board I'm sick of people saying that I
just wish you said it like this yeah so
then don't tell me how to say I need a
script next time I don't know what to
tell you if you wanted to talk to people
who talked like you just talk to
yourself that's so true you cannot say
baby names anymore like in this day and
age ever since had episode of Sex & City
you cannot say your baby names out loud
yeah the only silly girls do that yeah I
mean I guess if you are not Jewish
should you could both of them your kid
it well yeah then it's just confusing
like if the cousins are both named
Sandra I guess you guys can't hang out
anymore
so sad I think you have to get like a
new sister you have no you just have to
get over the name and maybe tell us
inning so we can tell you that it sucks
yeah you know what is yeah Kayla wasn't
even a good name to her made in Sex in
the City I agree
okay next dear toasters tear Claudia and
Jackie daily listener constant insist
ocker can't get enough testy content I
hope this question isn't too personal
for you guys I lost mine to have two and
a half years ago after he battled with
an autoimmune disease I'm getting
married in a few months and have been
avoiding thinking about how to address
those dad daughter moments at the
wedding I know you both lost your dad
before your wedding so I'm wondering who
worked you guys down the aisle did your
husband still dance with their moms even
though you dint do a daddy-daughter
dance any advice would be much
appreciated is there any other moments
that I'm missing this is such a good
cause
but it also didn't realize they make it
a lot easier in Jewish weddings because
in any Jewish wedding I've ever been to
both the mom and the dad walk the the
kid down the aisle so we walk down with
our mom which didn't seem like so crazy
because I've seen many moms walk down
the aisle like what yeah but in
non-jewish weddings it's always the dad
like you always have a father figure so
it feels like more of an absence there
yeah but I would say how do you mom I
don't think it's weird we're living in
2020 like gender roles what is mom what
is that
yeah actually she walked herself walk
yourself no what have your mom walk
you've had you're not so worried or if
there's been someone in your life who
was like filled the role of a father
figure who would be like so honored this
is like the episode of Friends where
Phoebe gets married and Phoebe had a
very untraditional childhood and
Chandler walks her down the aisle and
Joey and they were all just so honored
when she asks like there are people in
your life who helped you grow and if you
want to like be traditional have a man
do it I think you can find someone there
or just walk it by yourself and like you
could have a chair in the front row that
you leave open yes that's nice there's a
few things and there's a few things that
you could do our husbands still dance
with their moms right like why should
just because our dad died why should you
be ruined of the tradition yes he danced
with our mom so that works for us and
then I think there's a few nice ways
that you can honor people like you can
make a toast and like say in memory I
did a special cocktail like that was our
dad Steve oh they're so cute they called
it the Big O and it was like what he
would have drank if he was there I
there's a lot of ways you can get
creative with it I was one of the lucky
ones who got to use Daddy's Tallis in
the club that I lost it afterwards but I
found it so Mario can have it but I lost
it during Jackie and Lily's wedding
which is literally like my biggest
guilty like conscience in the world like
I want to come in like like just kill me
so that was nice I would love to hear
like what your background is you know
because we know Jewish traditions but
like if you have a if you're Greek
Orthodox you know I could do some
googling but I would need a little bit
more insight into what type of ceremony
you're having so justice of the peace
it's a priestess in the church but
there's there's a bunch of like secular
things I feel like like cute Pinterest e
things like yes I've actually seen a
girl that I know I'm she like a really
cute embroidering in her under dress
like not in her actual dress like in her
tulle I'm she like a abraca I thought it
was really cool
I don't know in the dress of the Father
Knows for a friend
Oh for a friend it's me and it was like
it was really cool I liked it that's
cool that's yeah there's a lot of ways
yeah honestly also the pizzas were
Pinterest this is what Pinterest was
made for yeah just google it yeah
there's some like I couldn't even think
of the things people on Pinterest to
totally I didn't even look there because
I knew what I wanted to do but you could
do like a giveaway like at one point I
wanted to do but because we're in the
city
like made no sense like our dad loves
cigars so if you gave away cigars with
like a little custom the thing that goes
around them yeah but then like where
would people smoke them in the city
nowhere but if you're doing an outdoor
wedding that could be really cool also
I've seen people have like pictures like
a table of pictures in the entry like of
all the people who couldn't be there you
know a grandparent you put in the
program yeah I like that I like that to
also include his name on the invitation
yeah I see some like you do it with a
little uh super calm like letters it's
like in like their memory but um you can
do that in English as well like I said
I'll just need some more info on your
background maybe your 23andme and then I
could give you some suggestions all
right final dear testers
I'm literally by the way I should let
everyone know that the dear toaster
segment is brought to you by bio clarity
which is an amazing green healthy
skincare brand that I found out from
Cinch because she's constantly
influencing me she was doing a face mask
and it was like Doody green and I'm like
Raisa Judy Huth and she said because
there's no [ __ ] paragraph parabens in
it and this is what face masks should
look like bio clarity is a clean and
green skincare brand that has products
that just worked their routines were
made up to help keep your skin looking
young healthy and fresh using only
natural and gentle products so I got a
bunch of the products after Margot
suggested them to me and then they
started sponsoring the Chou's which just
made it a lot easier and at first I was
a little put off by the color but I'm
like wait what a face mask is like or a
skin cream is white why is it why you
know like it actually makes sense it's a
plant base that looks green like I'd
actually mean it was really reassuring
for me so they have two routines to fit
your skin care needs the clear schemers
routine for combination oily or breakout
prone skin and they have the essentials
routine for normal or dry skin I think I
have normal to dry so I get like patchy
chin and nostril areas it's really sexy
their products are 100% vegan cruelty
free paraben free sulfate free
artificial fragrance free 100% risk free
money back guarantee so you could try it
out if you like it you can get healthier
more radiant skin by going to bio
clarity calm right now our listeners
will give you 40% off skincare routines
plus an additional 50% off everything on
their website that's an incredible deal
but you need to enter our code toast at
checkout so go to bio clarity calm and
get 40% of skincare routines plus an
additional 50% off everything on their
website when you use our code toast at
checkout Thank You Margot for
brightening my life my skin and my soul
that's what I'm here for here is our
third and final two your toasters again
if you want to participate in dear
toasters we always keep it anonymous
email us to do your toasters at
gmail.com
I'm literally so obsessed with the
morning toast and they listen every day
religiously on my way home from work
secretly wishing I was a boy with no job
I find great solace and listening to
your - listening to quite possibly the
most relatable and duo ever and I need
your help
sure I'm gay and I just moved to a new
city and I'm finally ready to date
someone like the Yuppie I am aspiring to
be I've been seeing this guy for about
two weeks and he is truly a precious gem
of a man I mean a premium boy he's so
kind and so sweet and so funny and so
cute and he likes being around me so
naturally I'm obsessed I told them
multiple times he is a major boyfriend
material the only thing that I have a
notorious habit of being overly eager at
the beginning of a relationship and
coming on too strong and ultimately self
sabotaging and scaring the poor guy off
taking things things low I don't know
her I have an incredibly loyal and
compulsive some would say obsessive
personality but I truly think it makes
me a better friend and hopefully a
better boyfriend I'm the definition of a
ride-or-die and personally I think it's
my way of showing my love and
appreciation for people in life no
question to you dear my question to you
dear toasters is how can i express my
desire to date this man long-term
without being perceived as psycho
aggressive or crazy we're getting to him
- this weekend I want to have it define
the relationship talk but I'm worried it
might be too soon he says emotional
availability is sexy and that he enjoys
straightforwardness but would that be
taking things too far too soon all I
really want is an open discussion about
boundaries and the potential of
exclusivity moving forward I really like
this guy and don't want to [ __ ] it up
please help sincerely the self saboteur
can I just say I really like that he
sees the quality in him south of like
being overeager as a positive because I
do too this is like my cross to bear
with bachelor in paradise it's like
since when is just like wanting to be
with one person and liking them and
being upfront about it makes you crazy
I don't know but that is the world that
we live in and I would suggest maybe
waiting like a week or two just because
I don't think you're doing anything
wrong but the world that we live in
perceive someone who's just ready to
settle down and and who's a nice guy it
perceives you as crazy so if you don't
want to if you want to avoid that I
might suggest just like waiting a week
or two to have that conversation because
two weeks is kind of short and I know
that you see it as like you're you are
ready and I totally believe you but the
world that we live in makes these social
constructs and I would suggest waiting
me I I agree with that and I ice
think you can't go wrong doing that but
I don't know how much of a difference
two weeks is gonna make if this person
like is really so averse and it's gonna
take it badly two weeks prior they might
not see the good quality need two weeks
later and I also feel like this is such
a wonderful quality in you that the
right person is gonna really appreciate
it but no guy is averse to it no and
there's a way to say it that that's not
like clingy and crazy where it's just
like I'm not asking to be exclusive I
just want to make sure we're on the same
page where it's like I'm really enjoying
hanging out i I can see things like
going there with you
one day I just want to make sure you're
open to that too like you want to be in
a relationship and you want to be
exclusive down the line not right now
like I think just getting on the same
page setting expectations setting
expectations it's not that snot crazy
saying to someone after two weeks of
dating like I just want to make sure
with you that like you want to be in a
relationship eventually but isn't the
assumption that if you're going on dates
with someone that though the goal is a
long-term relationship demon Kayla no
right that was so far strange when
everyone's just hooking up honestly I
sadly don't think you can assume that
and it he's writing in asking what to do
like I think he knows that maybe I mean
two weeks is super short so maybe where
we are just hooking up and having fun
mm-hmm
you know it also depends what you're
doing like if you're hooking up with
someone and like you're only seeing them
late at night and then you think of the
the endgame is gonna be a relationship
like that's on you kind of but if you're
going out to dinner every night go to
the movies like going on real dates he
walks you home like spending sober time
together right that is much more of like
you can assume a relationship is gonna
be down the line but it really depends
on what the activities are that you're
participating in yeah and I think the
way that you approach the conversation
like don't be like we need to have a
discussion but be talking about life
love the pursuit of happiness and then
be like what do you see for yourself
like are you looking to be in a
relationship soon like or is that
something that you're interested in so
it's like not like you were premeditated
you know it just happened to come up in
conversation can I just say like the
more we do deer toasters and just like
the more I get people dating advice the
more excited I am to be married no I
agree and everyone's commenting it is
not
assumption that everyone is entire but
you know I refuse like I want to live in
the Taylor Swift world where she wears
high-waisted shorts and like lives in
Connecticut you don't even like whatever
happened to just like dating for the
sake of getting married you know that's
like a what's the word I'm looking for
it's a go rarity anomaly anomaly yeah it
just depends also depends how you meet
and I think there's a lot of different
factors that have made that not so like
social media dating apps
I think alcohol is like at an all-time
high don't you feel like people are just
drinking more than ever these things
like that was on a random like at like 3
p.m. I don't know if it's always been
that way and now that we're adults like
I always think back to like when I was a
child and where events where like
parents were like getting together and
everyone's like drinking wine but you
just but were they getting [ __ ] up
there too I think so but you're talking
about events which I think drinking at a
party has always been a thing but now
people just drink for the bachelor they
drink for like everything and I have to
believe that it's at an all-time high
I don't drink at home I really don't
unless like having a dinner party I've
never like opened a glass of wine and
drank it in bed before watching The
Bachelor
or like made myself a shot it's icky it
like I just never done that and I think
it's like like a bad habit yeah well for
some people it's that's what they enjoy
but I think even in TV shows now it's
like every time someone's at home they
have a large glass of wine like I just
think and then when you are drinking
more like relationships are less
meaningful less meaningful because like
you're not you can't be like drunk in a
relationship forever so it's certain
point people sober up and maybe you're
not as interesting or they're
interesting and maybe yeah they're not
as pretty and it's just not all there so
I think between all of those things it
makes it harder to find like real
relationships no I don't do not envy you
snitch it's torture so is the fact that
I have to go wait oh so bad I'm trying
so hard to keep it well we're gonna wrap
it up that was your toasters feel free
to email us to your toasters at
gmail.com I could use some more
interesting dear toasters like the girl
with the beard whatever happened to her
like I just went yeah or the girl with
the water bottles I just want to know
give me weirder ones those are good but
I could stand a little bit more of the
weird and crazy thank you guys so much
for listening to the Millenial morning
showed the morning toast we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube so feel free to give
this video with
if you're watching on YouTube and
subscribe we've just hit 44,000 we like
gotta get to a hundred um so I tell your
friend and like make if all the people
who already subscribed to us could just
make a second YouTube account then we'd
be like so much closer to a hundred I
would be super grateful make it a suit
yeah if you're also the same trust on
podcasts were available anywhere pop
cats can be found that's out of a defy
iTunes Spotify iHeartRadio stitcher like
literally anywhere you can listen to
podcasts so feel free to leave a review
there five stars subscribe there we're
gonna release an episode of the snatch
alert today the snapshot is back on
iTunes so feel free to leave her a
review even if you already did we did
lose all of them which was super sad so
we got about a thousand back which we're
super appreciative appreciative of this
episode it will be up in a few hours and
it's also available on Spotify that has
remained untouched I think that's all
the announcements for today we will see
you guys tomorrow for a final episode of
the week because we are taking a long
weekend for Labor Day weekend to it then
Friday there will be an episode up on
patreon toast radio which I'm so excited
to record and rip it out so you'll have
episodes galore galore bye
you